we we must do something about the the
certainly the investment that china is
making in cyber and ai as well because
in certain spheres i believe they are
very much ahead of us if we're not
concerned about that we should be
and i want to do something about it
we weren't training effectively i wanted
to solve that and i figured that
augmented reality up in the sky was the
way to do it we've created the world's
first military metaverse up in the sky
which allows real pilots and real
airplanes to grow up in real airplanes
and train against virtual airplanes that
are not really there
red six is a technology company focused
on solving a national security crisis i
was an f22 partner for the us air force
and when i flew we didn't have any uh
enough training so i wanted to be able
to provide enough training that was
relevant
by using an alternative approach the
beautiful thing with this visor is we
see the real world around us
as normal the only difference is now
when we look through the visor we see
synthetic entities augmented reality
aeroplanes every time a fighter pilot
goes up to flying train they need
someone to go fly and train against at a
very simple level and you can
extrapolate that across big formations
those numbers become pretty demanding
and significant and so we didn't have
enough pilots we didn't have enough
airplanes and we didn't have the dollars
to solve that problem the whole reason i
started this company is pilots must fly
we can't do this in simulators we've got
to be able to fly so how do we fly
efficiently but we need to be more
sophisticated in thinking about it in
terms of the amount of flight hours my
contention is it's actually the number
of times that our pilots are exposed to
a given problem set and how many times
can you repeat that one of the beautiful
things about this technology is
we can go up into the airspace and let's
say we go into the airspace with a
traditional airplane against another
airplane we may get three looks at a
given problem set before we run out of
fuel have to go to a tank or come back
home the beautiful thing with this
technology is it's reset reset reset so
in that given set of maybe let's say
it's a one flight hour where
traditionally you'd maybe get three
looks at a problem set you may get eight
nine ten looks at a problem set using
this over the next 12 to 18 months
you'll see this technology flying around
in an air force fighter currently we're
working with the united states air force
to integrate into the t-38 which is down
at holmen with the the test pilot
community down there that's an
incredibly exciting moment for us
because to see this stuff flying in an
air force jet
i mean we're doing a very difficult
thing right we're doing
cutting-edge technology and then asking
the us air force to put in an airplane
with human beings the commitment of the
u.s air force on the signal by being
awarded a silver phase three or seventy
million dollars is a huge signal that
the air force believes in what we're
doing and i really believe they get this
vision